hi everyone it's an honor to share our
work
with you today i'm going to introduce
our work
unravelingly starting code 19 virus
polymerase complex structure
using claudia
we know that corner wires are positive
and
single strand rna virus
after it invades an infectious cells
the first directly used its own
positives as rna genome
to translate and synthesize rna
polymerase
subsequently rna polymerase synthesize
anti-science rna with its genome at
template and then transcribe message
rnas
with this anticipate genome rna to
obtain the expression of
each coding protein this anti-size
rna is also used as a template
to reproduce new genome and resemble new
virus
this transcription and replication
process is
carried out by rna polymerase after
years of
careful study number 12
non-structural protein were identified
as rna-dependent rna polymerase
rdrp protein interaction network
analysis
show that the colorados can assemble an
efficient
and somewhat profitable molecular
machine
with the rna polymerase as the code and
cofactor non-structured protein 7
and 8 as the primaries
and some other non-structural proteins
to ensure
an efficient transcription and
replication
of a large rna genome with a loss of
about 30 000 base pairs
interfering with activity of rna
polymerase
one of the most important antiviral
targets
is the heart of the transcription on the
replication machine
as expected to prevent the virus from
replication
at the most recent ones from the
silverware
and the viral parallel are the projects
that
target rna polymerase with their
metabolites
chromium analysis of polymerase and the
minor eukasic binding protein will
encounter the preferred
specimens orientation issue during
electrification
usually we have some ways to solve this
problem
such as using fusion protein or antibody
to alter the orientation distribution
or you use a low concentration of
detergent
and you could change the surface tension
or use thin carbon film commonly used
for the
large samples different sample
preparation approach such as speed
of bloating free ritualification
or collect image from two displacements
we have been studying some number of
protein complex structure for a long
time
so we give preference to detergent
solution
which gives us the missing orientation
projection
finally and the subsequent
typical data precising precise
accelerated by crop spark
result in a high quality reconstruction
of 2.9 ice storm in two days
the 2.9 astronomer complex structure
showed that
the rna polymerase of codonite virus
had consumed typical are viral rna
polymerase structure
and an iron characterized domain often
needle virus
at the include typical palm fingers
and thumb domain the viral rna
polymerase and sp12
form a complex ways one where
non-structure protein
speed 7 and 2 and sp8
as early as 2010 it was found out
intermittent domain of the soft coronary
rna polymerase seems to be particularly
important to the correct folding and
activity of this enzyme
defects in n-terminal are the presence
of
artificial introduced redundant amino
acid ratios
can significantly affect the stability
and
activity of the polymerase
mutagenesis analysis show that is unique
in terminal and iron domain
has a profound effect on viral
replication
[Music]
what is exciting is that all structure
completes
this entire domain information that has
been missing in a previous
research on source corners rna
polymerase
for the first time a unique hierophant
domain
was revealed
we can see this harping interacts with
both
and iran domain and the palm domain
what's more as has been reported that
zinc ions shows reversibly inhibition
effect on cholera replication in
virtually in cell culture
we found died to typical zinc iron
binding sites on this polymerase
exhibit different i think on body state
under different purification conditions
which may provide a perspective for
understanding the inhibitory effect of
zinc ions
meanwhile by comparing with the
polymerase hcv
and the polyvarious the typical template
entry channel between the motif
g and motif 5 nucleotides
unchanged channel between motif e and
motif
if and the products in this channel
in coordinating various properties can
be formed
even more by comparing with the complex
structure
of hepatitis c virus polymerase and as
file b under the first barrier we
propose a possible recognization
mode of relay syria we also discuss some
possible similarity and
difference between the two similarly
viral parallel another nucleotide analog
may work through a similar mechanism
if we have a little imagination and
considering
the possible parts and more interaction
of the template and
the product rna we can provide an
overall scenario in which
cholera's rna synthesis is inhibited by
new
nucleoside analogs
of course the real picture will involve
the high old structure of rna
and other members of the transcription
replication complex
such as primaries and hypotheses
there is a long way to go in fact
since the outbreak of morrow's corners
the corner of us has changed from a
newly emerging virus to
a re-emerging and widespread virus
in the future we may continue to face
destruction of carnal virus for a long
time
fortunately not only the efficiency of
broad spectrum or polymerase anti-white
inhibitors
show oncologism but also the
conservation
of sp12 compared to the evolving
proteins such as
spikes they both suggest that polymerase
is a promising and valuable target for
broad
spectrum annual viral turkish drugs
development
despite some significant side effects
nuclear retired animals that targeted
the polymerase
may indeed be an effective drug
candidate
against infectious disease particularly
virus finally i would like to pay
an exceptional tribute to shanghai tech
university and
their administration as well as about
the election mexico facility for their
great
care and support to our research team to
enable us
carry all this research in a safe and
healthy
environment it would have been
impossible
for us to get this work done without
madness eiffels
in the last two months during the
coordinating pandemic
on behalf of our team i also
would like to convince our spy shows
like
to chinhwa university to their
exceptional permission to allow students
to go back to their laboratory
to prepare the protein samples for this
study
we also must express our grateful
to the campus service team of shanghai
attack university scientific
research platform of shanghai institute
for
other wars in chemical study and
national center for parkinson's shanghai
as well as all the managers and
technician individuals who provide
onsite or remote technical support
there can't help and fearless support
of power tool to our work during the
epidemic we would like to thank
the university of queensland and the
diamond light source for their
collaboration
thanks for your attention and i would
like to answer
any question you have
thanks juan and now over to renhon
hello everyone this is from west lake
university
and the postdoc of daughter igongshu and
the daughter
chancho thanks the webinar organizers
for
giving me this opportunity to show our
recent work
about the structural basis for the
recognition
of the south korea 2 by full-length
human h2
the outbreak of clonal virus disease
2019
has emerged as a serial pandemic
this disease is caused by subscribe to
a positive strain on a virus there are
over 2 million people who has been
infected
by susquehan and over 100 thousand
people
dying from this disease such kobe 2
also called 2019 inquiry is one kind
of coronal viruses which are important
pathogens for human being there are four
genera
of clonal viruses such kobe 2 belongs to
the beta clonal virus
susque 2 is an overlapped virus with
about 30 kilobase rna which can produce
9 major subgenomic rnas among these
viral proteins
as protein on a viral surface mediates
receptor recognition and the membrane
fusion
for the life cycle of human colon
viruses
this clonal viruses enter hosts the
cells
by first binding to the risk active
cellular receptor cellular s-protein
then the conformational change of
s-protein
leads to virus and the cell membrane
fusion and the viral end chain
after entering into the host cells the
virogenomic
rna is released and translated into
viral proteins
these proteins are further assembled in
the er and the golgi
intermediate compartment to form a
material
viral then releasing from the host
cells for susque 2
the sequence is highly similar to
another
non-virus susque which has
caused the serial acute respiratory
syndrome
in 2003 in china so
the scientists wonder will the susqueh2
assassinate
share the same cellular receptor it's
two
then two independent groups use the
viral infection as they
suggest that these two is the cellular
receptor of
susquehanna and the cytoscopy too
[Music]
the crystal structure of succulent
receptor binding domain
in complex with peptides domain of
s2 has been solved in 2005.
before we did this project all the
structures of
s2 only contain peptides domain
that of the full length protein
remains unknown the full name of
s2 is called angiotensin converting
enzyme 2 s2 is a single transmembrane
protein
which contains an n-terminal peptidis
domain
and the c-terminal collection-like
domain the mainly function
of s2 is haploid maturation of
angiotensin
a peptide hormone that controls muscle
constriction
and the blood pressure beside the least
the s protein of cytoscopy and the
subscribe to
can bind to the peptides domain of s2
as for the collection-like domain
previous
studies showed that the cleavage of c
terminal of
s2 can significantly enhance the viral
infection
the single transmembrane helix of s2
makes it a challenging to determine the
structure of
the full length s2 protein
so we did literature research and
tried to find a binding pattern with
these two
and we found that s2 also functions
as the chaperone for membrane
trafficking of the amino acid
transporter
better one that one is also known as slr
c6a19
which can transport neutral amino acids
such as losing in the kidney and the
intensity
so we wonder that the structure of full
length
is 2 might be reviewed in the presence
of
that one then we co-expressed the
s2 and the beta 1 complex in 293 f
cells and the successfully purified the
homogeneous complex
you can see that the behavior of this
complex is
quite good and
use the good behavioral protein we
make the claw yam sample you can see
the particles is quite good and the 2d
classification shows a good feature for
this membrane complex
however the data processing for this
complex is not
easy to do it took us a lot of time to
solve the structure of
s2 and the beta1 complex because
when the outbreak of korean 19 i was on
my
spring festival holiday at home then we
realized the variety of list pandemic
and go back to lab to speed up this
project
after hard working we successfully
solved a 2.9 armstrong structure
of s2 and the baton complex
the high resolution supported reliable
model building
you can see this structure is very
beautiful
the h2 and the bed one complex is
assembled as a diameter of
keto diamonds with the collection-like
domain of its two
mediating hormone diameterization
we can see the hormone damarization
entirely mediated by s2 which is
damaged by fat 1 between the peptides
domain and the transmembrane helix
is a neck domain both the peptides
domain
and the next domain contribute to
dimerization
with multiple interactions based on
residues
of s2 during the data processing
we also found about 20
particles showed a different
confirmation
at the peptides domain of these we call
it
open confirmation the previous one is
called
close the confirmation
we can see that the major difference
between
the open and close the confirmation of
s2
is let the peptides domain are separated
away
in the open conformation and the
closed conformation has closed the
peptides domain
you can see the s protein of sas kov2
contains
1273
amino acids with a single transmembrane
domain
the functional s protein is assembled as
timer
the receptor binding domain mediates the
binding with peptides domain of
s2 the extracellular domain of s
protein of succule2 has been soft
which is quite similar with the
s-protein of
sasquary then we bought
some receptor binding domain protein
from signal biological company
and incubated the receptor bending
domain of s-protein
with s2 and the bet1 complex
and prepared the claw em sample after 2d
classification we found an extended
density
above s2 we speculated the least density
might belongs to the
receptor bending domain of s protein
the structure of the ternary complex was
determined
to earn overall resolution of 2.9
armstrong however the resolution for the
h2
and the bat one complex was higher
landlord for the
receptor bending domain because there is
that the bending domain is at the
periphery of the complex
so in order to improve the local
resolution
focused refinement was applied this
allowed us to reach a resolution of
3.5 armstrong for the receptive planning
domain
supporting reliable model building and
analysis of the interface
so as we can see each peptide's domain
accommodates one receptor bending domain
and extended loop region of the receptor
bending domain
spans the arch shaped f1 helix
of the peptides domain of s2 it's just
like a bridge
so when we zoom in the interfaces we can
see the interfaces
are mainly mediated through polar
interactions
there are multiple interfaces
in this complex when compared with the
crystal structure
of susquehanna receptor binding domain
and the peptides domain of
s2 we found the overall interface
is similar with the number of sequence
variations
and the conformational deviations are
found in the
respective interfaces to
confirm our structure we aligned
our chromium structure with the crystal
structures
of cytoscopy 2 receptor bending domain
in complex with peptides domain of
s2 and the founder interfaces are almost
identical among these structures
maybe you remember that i have ever said
that
previous studies showed that cleavage of
the c-terminal segments
of the s2 especially residues
697 to 716
of s2 by proteins such as tmprss
can enhance the s-protein-driven viral
entry
this region from the third and the first
helix
in the next domain of s2 and
involved in the dynamic interface
of s2 you can see this
the presence of bad one might block the
axis of tmpr ss2 to the cutting side
on s2
based on these findings we proposed
a simple working model for susquehanna
infection
one is to stay alone the s protein binds
to the peptides domain of
s2 and the start infection process
the tmpr ss2 can catalyze the terminal
of s2
to enhance viral energy one is to stay
with that one
that one might protect to from pmpr
access to digesting so that one might
play an
important regulatory role for the viral
infection
process so
what we can do with this complex
structure
first we can use list structure to do
drug design
to block the banding between receptor
binding domain
and s2 let's protecting host cells from
viral infection
we can also use this structure to
optimize the neutralizing antibodies
this structure can also help with the
development
of vaccine
finally i would like to thank professor
igungs
and daughter chanzo for the support and
help
i would like to thank the hard working
of our team members
the western lake university cloud em
center
and the supercomputer center this work
was the party the balance
national natural science foundation of
china
the south korea two emergency projects
of department of science
and the technology of the german
province
the key program of the young province